state vedendo un
cellula umana della pelle che si muove
attorno
guidata
la mente dalla luce che lo illumina si
muove in maniera intelligente
segue delle direzioni ben precise non
urta l'ostacolo ma poi decide di
rivolgere la sua attenzione proprio
quella fonte luminosa che è una luce
bianca fredda che pulsa la cellula si
sintonizza ha distrutto da parte di sé
per andare a toccare sempre vibrando
quella luce dietro questa dinamica
c'è una oscillazione continua di
microtubuli di filamenti che sono dentro
di noi con una tra la tessile che si
muove di continuo e oggi sappiamo che
crea comunicazione genera informazione
diffonde informazione contemporaneamente
è un oscillazione meccanica ma si tratta
di strutture altamente polarizzate
quindi un'oscillazione elettrica anche
elettromagnetica e la cosa che ci ha
sorpreso di più non si l'azione luminosa
questi microtubuli questi filamenti
possono legare sostanze che assorbono ed
emettono radiazioni elettromagnetiche
luce quindi dentro di noi abbiamo un
vero e proprio circuito bioelettronico
una matrice intelligente e quelle che
abbiamo pensato essere le molecole
segnare le proteine non si incontrano
solo toccandosi come una chiave è una
serratura ma vibrano oscillano e si
riconoscono danzando come in fase
pensate per un attimo alle mani di un
pianista che suona questa matrice e ne
cambia
contestualmente l'oscillazione meccanica
i colori i connotati elettrici
elettromagnetici pensate per un attimo
questo radio come alla molecola una
molecola che scilla e la rete
vedete si muove con lui come la rete dei
microtubuli è come dire che una singola
entità vibrazionale in questa rete fa sì
che con la rete stessa esibisca
consapevolezza e quando abbiamo più
entità in questa rete con questo caso
tanti esserini che si muovono nella
nella rete del
sembra che si muovono in maniera
assolutamente caotica disordinata ma
piano piano vedrete che vanno in fase
cioè si riconoscono senza toccarsi
cominciano ad alzare a coppie e poi pian
piano si crea un processo di
informazione quindi la rete in qualche
modo dissipa queste differenze
vibrazionali e riconoscendosi a distanza
e vibrando in fase le nostre molecole
creano informazioni quindi abbiamo
cellule che sono contemporaneamente
sensori e attuatori di energie fisiche
questo per esempio quello che abbiamo
fatto di recente abbiamo creato un micro
cuore in vitro lavorando su cellule
staminali con un campo radioelettrico
opportunamente orientato ogni puntino a
una cellula che si contrae e quindi ecco
l'idea come sentivamo prima di una nuova
medicina rigenerativa ma possiamo fare
di più con dei microscopi particolari
che si chiamano microscopio a forza
atomica possiamo sfruttare una loro sol
da piccolissima termina con un solo
atomo per cui possiamo toccare le nostre
cellule sentire come sono fatto eppure
sentire come vibrano con opportuni
accorgimenti abbiamo sviluppato quella
che chiamiamo sono citologia ci possiamo
sentire i suoni di queste cellule questo
che sentite adesso è un suono di una
singola cellula di lievito una cellula
molto semplice ma molto studiata che sta
metabolizzando un substrato a 22 gradi
quando cambiamo la temperatura cambia la
velocità con cui quei geni lavorano ne
diciamo si esprimono
ecco sentite 20
malgrado il successo sentite come è
cambiato il suono sentite adesso a 30
gradi come cambiate più acute parlo di
suoni perché se foriamo con la cellula
abbiamo un rumore di toni
ecco allora che esiste forse un codice
oscillatorio un codice vibrazionale che
ci racconta quello che stanno facendo le
cellule abbiamo pensato di applicare una
medicina rigenerativa alle nostre
cellule staminali e qui vedete in alto a
sinistra una cellula cardiaca umana che
si contrae che batte l'abbiamo ottenuta
da un fibroblast di cuore opportunamente
riprogrammato quel triangolino il
braccino di quel microscopio a forza
atomica quello potete vederlo lo potete
vedere la sonda che molto piccola
termina con un solo atomo ma potete
vedere in alto a destra quella
vibrazione di cui parlo quella sorta di
firma vibrazionale anche questa possiamo
renderla udibile in questo caso per
farla sentire abbiamo modulato un la una
nota musicale registrata a 432
con questa firma oscillatoria delle
cellule questo movimento verticale delle
cellule
questo movimento orizzontale si sommano
insieme ora quando cerchiamo di portare
questi suoni una cellula staminale del
grasso
ecco cosa succede abbiamo creato delle
macchine degli attuatori cioè qualcosa
che trasferisce in maniera altamente
fedele questo suono che avete udito
questa vibrazione eco vedete dopo due
settimane
questa cellula del grasso comincia a
diventare una cellula miocardica che
batte che si contrae un micro cuore in
vitro
in altri termini queste cellule sono
diventate qualcosa in cui non si
sarebbero mai altrimenti trasformate
ecco l'idea di una nuova medicina
rigenerativa sfruttare questi codici
comprenderli e sfruttare il potenziale
diffusivo di queste energie fisiche
siamo permeabili ai suoni siamo
permeabili alla luce nel vicino
infrarosso ai campi elettromagnetici
quindi possiamo raggiungere le cellule
staminali dove già si trovano e sono
presenti in tutti i tessuti del corpo
umano le possiamo riprogrammare per fare
una medicina rigenerativa che non abbia
più bisogno in prima istanza del
trapianto di cellule tessuti ma che va
da potenziare qualcosa che tutti abbiamo
dentro si chiama potenziale di auto
guarigione ma se pensiamo ai suoni e
movimenti a liberazione e colori beh
questi sono da sempre gli strumenti
dell'espressione artistica dell'uomo
così nel 2016 sul palcoscenico del
teatro san leonardo di bologna insieme a
milford grace che una leggenda perché
hanno le percussioni jazz e alessandro
bergonzoni un attore unico del suo
genere
c'erano cellule staminali umane del
grasso sul piano di lavoro di un
microscopio equipaggiato con una
telecamera iperspettrale la telecamera
capace di cogliere le vibrazioni emesse
da queste cellule farle vedere anche al
pubblico che la spettatore si
trasformava inesplorato
ed ecco che la nostra sorpresa è stata
grande quando abbiamo visto che al
variare della performance del
percussionista queste cellule cambiavano
il loro ritmo la loro vibrazione era
prima una risonanza passiva andavano
dietro a quello che faceva l'artista ma
poi sviluppavano un ritmo loro proprio
poi ho chiesto
diciamo un po senza rete da alessandro
bergonzoni di fare tre cose di recitare
un brano con voce urlata stentorea un
brano molto comico un grano surreale e
una preghiera che avesse dovuto
improvvisare alle cellule e abbiamo
campionato momenti di suono identico
perchè lui si spostavano quel
palcoscenico quando ha raccontato
qualcosa di comico e surreale gridando
tanto si attivano solo la superficie
delle cellule e lì in alto a destra
quando parlava le cellule a un certo
punto ha chiesto se essendo loro
staminali per caso non fossero in grado
anche di rigenerarsi e sollevarci della
nostra triste condizione umana che
emerge in tanti contesti bene lì pur
campionando momenti di sono della stessa
intensità si è attivato il nucleo
abbiamo pubblicato questo anche su una
buona rivista internazionale ecco quindi
che ogni manifestazione artistica può
parlare a dinamiche più profonde della
nostra biologia e allora visto che
l'abbiamo sentito prima
siamo parte della natura vibratoria
dell'universo ma come un universo così
nella biologia
noi non vediamo tutte le radiazioni
elettromagnetiche il nostro dna solo un
im per cento che funziona e che
chiamiamo geni ma il resto epigenetica
sentiamo vibrazioni con l'orecchio da 20
a 20 mila hearts però possiamo sentire
altre cose sappiamo che cosa è bello per
noi adesso sappiamo che forse questa
bellezza questa risonanza questo amore
abbiamo abbiamo paura di pronunciare
questa questa parola forse fanno vibrare
in fase le nostre celle
ora siamo ben di più che una macchina
perfetta cerchiamo di usarci al meglio
che possiamo
grazie
[Applauso]